are back in kindergarten playing in the
sandbox with other children each of you
have your own permanent allotted space
inside the sandbox to do anything you
want one day the kindergarten teacher
announces a sandcastle building
competition you have one hour to build
it and to get a prize the sandcastle has
to be taller than 1 meter the clock
starts and you get to work
[Music]
an hour later the teacher tells all of
you to stop and measure the sand castles
many of them surpass 1 meter but yours
is around 90 centimeters so you don't
get a prize whose fault is that well
it's yours right you had the time you
had the sand others could do it you
couldn't thus you cannot blame anything
or anyone else you are personally
responsible for your sandcastle not
reaching one meter
but what if as you were building the
sand castle another child kicked it over
and you had to start again because of
that you couldn't build it tall enough
in time and didn't get the prize are you
personally responsible then most people
would say no so these are some clear-cut
examples but life is rarely that simple
turns out the sand inside the sandbox is
not homogeneous in some areas there is
lots of cool wet sticky sand perfect for
building other areas have less some
barely any what if you're a lot of space
has very little sand is it your fault
that if you can't complete the task in
time not really right obviously the
kindergarten teacher should have made
sure that all kids have more equal
amounts of scent to build with before
announcing the competition or at the
very least there shouldn't be any gross
differences they could have dug up the
sandbox a bit mix it up a bit so the
quality is more even but if they did
parents of the children with lots of
sand might come in the next day
screaming saying how nobody can
redistribute any of their children's
sand because it was them the parents who
carried their own buckets and their
parents before them and so on so their
child can build the tallest best looking
sandcastle now they've built up all that
generational sand and nobody has the
right to take any of it but if the
teacher did redistribute the sand it
would only have been a minor
inconvenience for the sand rich children
but for the children with little sand it
would have made all the difference we
know this because this has been standard
practice in u.s kindergartens after
world war ii right until the reagan
administration and its standard practice
right now in europe producing better
outcomes than in the us on the other
hand even hey child has very little
scent to start with they can get
somewhere from the janitor across the
yard who has a big sand container but
doing so takes time and effort and some
of it falls out of your container on the
way also the janitor doesn't give the
same amount to everyone if you have a
study badge he generally gives you a lot
if you don't you get much less but the
thing is in u.s kindergartens you can
only get a study badge in exchange for a
lot of sand in european kindergartens
most children get study badges for free
for many us children with little to no
scent to start with a study badge is not
an option they are stuck with running
back and forth between the sand
container and the sandbox carrying only
smaller amounts in a toy bucket what
little they have is further diminished
by them having to rent the playset which
contains the aforementioned toy bucket
if they don't want to rent a playset
they can always buy one but especially
in urban kindergartens playsets are sold
for exorbitant amounts of sand thus are
completely unaffordable for most
children they have to rent the playset
meaning they can only fill the toy
bucket up to two-thirds half or even
one-third at a time the rest is taken by
the owner of the playset as rent these
owners are other children who then use
descend to give them to build their own
sandcastles higher so the competition
starts and the children with abundant
stands start building immediately other
children with little sand start running
back and forth between the sandbox and
the sand container with partially full
toy buckets in addition if they fall and
hurt themselves during goldie running
around the janitor will treat their
injury only in exchange for a lot of
sand in europe the kindergarten teachers
are responsible for the treating of
wounds not the janitors and they do it
in exchange for a small recurring sand
contribution after an hour the
competition is over the children who
started with lots of sand all have big
tall nice looking sand castles the
children who started with little to no
sand have smaller sand castles despite
having worked much harder the children
with lots of sand only had to run to the
janitor for more sand once per minute
the children with little to no scent had
to run twice or even three times and yet
the former group passed the one meter
mark and gota prize while the letter
didn't and so the question is are the
children with little to no sand
personally responsible for their failure
according to ben shapiro and people like
him yes but for people who aren't rich
sociopaths the answer would be no
clearly the children's family background
plays a huge role in whether they'll be
successful or not and family is one of
those things you cannot choose
well
excuse me liberal let's say a child is
born into a poor family let's say very
poor very very poor why doesn't the
child just leave their family and get
adopted by a richer family they consider
me sort of a widget in whatever ideology
they're pushing or or they're
considering the value of systems or not
systems but you sort of end around that
and i think that in many ways that's
what members of the left find so so
threatening is because if you're a
member of the left and you believe that
all individuals are essentially just the
outgrowths of institutions and therefore
that all change by individuals is going
to be insufficient and that it must be
societal change that that creates
individual change you're a threat
because you're telling people well you
know the systems can certainly get
better but the main threat to you is you
and that is a deeply threatening message
to people and if people find fulfillment
in that message then the left really
does have a problem because if people
start improving their lives within the
system
and not blaming the system for their
problems and instead recognizing that
that they can improve their lives that's
what members love tape most of all you
know you talk about in the book jordan
the fact that people are constantly
coming up to you and they're saying
things like you know i i
was leading a dissolute life i read your
book i started taking your advice and
i've turned it around and now i'm doing
much better in life and you know i'm
blessed to have much the same experience
from a lot of people who listen to the
show people who have been homeless who
now have graduated harvard law school
people who were single moms and and then
and then decided to to take a college
course and and figure out their lives
people who have made mistakes and turn
their mistakes around and to me those
are inspirational stories i think that
because those inspirational stories
exist that i think is why people find
you to be such a threat it's because so
many people are inspired by the stuff
that you say and change their life
individually without putting all of
their iron focus on a system that the
left is mainly focused on tearing down
i defy anyone to go read 10 000
comments on my youtube channels people
like ben shapiro want to offer an
individualist solution to a systemic
problem the extreme version of this
argument would be the following imagine
that during the days of slavery one of
the slaves complained about well being a
slave to which ben shapiro would respond
by telling them to take personal
responsibility and just escape to the
north slavery he'd say will not be
solved through big government overreach
that would be british imperialism the
north is there is an opportunity for
anyone willing to take it clearly the
slaves in the south just aren't trying
hard enough i get success stories all
the time from slaves who did try hard
and did escape to the north and are now
living a happy and free life but these
voke abolitionists only want to talk
about ending slavery on a federal level
but ignore what the slaves themselves
could do to change their own situation
alright now this is not to say that
personal responsibility is not important
it is obviously nobody is denying that
the idea that the left ignores personal
responsibility is an imagined hypocrisy
a right-wing shoutman can gesture
towards what percentage of the left
ignores personal responsibility can we
get some hard numbers please individual
anecdotes and twitter screenshots aren't
data by the way some problems are too
large and complex to be solved on an
individual level for example the us
obesity epidemic will not be solved
through just encouraging people to eat
healthy and work out more the first half
of the real solution is the authorities
better regulating the food industry what
type of sugar can be used how many grams
per unit can be in our food stuff giving
tax incentives to healthier products
limiting the amount of saturated fats
per serving and so on the other part of
this solution is creating walkable
cities where people don't sit in their
cars for two to four hours per day but
one core cycle to the store to work or
to public transportation once you have
the systemic solutions in progress then
you can start with the individualistic
solutions parallel to it so remember
when it comes to large complex problems
individual approach for rare exceptions
and systemic approach for results in the
meantime thank you for watching and
don't forget to like and subscribe and a
special thanks to the artist soleiman t
who created this awesome thumbnail for
this video you'll find the link to his
instagram in the description and i'll be
seeing you next time